joining us now to talk about all of it
is my colleague from the NFL Media Group
who first noticed Colin Kaepernick
sitting during the national anthem in a
preseason game in 2016 my buddy Steve
watch how are you Steve are you doing
man I'm doing fine were you so uh were
you on that you were on that video
conference right on Friday the four
league employees can you walk everybody
through what you were willing to share
from that yeah I mean myself and mg
Acosta actually moderated I okay then um
so we kind of of some of the discussions
experts in different forms of race and
society and things like this so without
giving away too much because it wasn't
in house meeting somebody know Roger
Goodell came on and addressed all the
employees on the call and he stayed he
know the league was going to do certain
things this and that and it came back
and told us that he would be dropping
the video that we now saw a little bit
later in the day and what that meant but
he did not disclose some of the things
in there such as you know through their
support
you know black lives matter you know
they addressed everything that the
players had addressed in their video but
rich this meeting was like nothing I've
ever experienced in terms of it very
much resemble what's going on in the
street it was young people the young
employees of the NFL telling a lot of
their pain addressing on how they felt
neglected by the NFL in-house as
employees and they were speaking
directly to the commissioner and all of
the executives are on the call I mean it
was you know I'm 54 years old now and
I'm looking back at myself a man hurt 25
where I have the stones to speak to the
big boss like these people did it was
jarring it was moving it was
inspirational and trust me it got it got
the attention of a lot of people not
just me but this
the shot-callers in the NFL the NFL
Network NFL Films and you know I think
by the time that call ended 90 minutes
or two hours later I don't think I got
up out of the chair I was sitting there
for 30 minutes no kidding I yeah rich I
was exhausted I was inspired it was it
was like what what are we about to see
here because there's you know you have
this sense of is something really gonna
happen like you you feel like something
may really happen like you know so many
times in American history when we drive
flashpoints like Christine back at 2016
do you have a cap shut down for the
national anthem will preceding that with
a shooting deaths of of so many black
men unarmed black men by police it was
very similar there were people in the
streets not not not a lot as loud as you
but it went away and now we're back here
and that cycles happened so many times
in American history but from what I'm
seeing when I got that call I'm like
something they actually freaking happen
and it was really I mean something NFL
you know you you could see that this was
not something that was done by giving
ownership heads-up you know this was
like Roger Goodell and the NFL taking
care of its own house and that's
something we a lot of times we don't see
rich you and I both know this you know a
lot of things are done for the approval
of that we know 32 owners how can he
pacify all 32 or at least a majority of
them this was how can we pacify the
people who work for this organization
not pacify but address the people who
work for this organization before we
even start spreading our wings so it's
the first time I think some real
housekeeping took place as to where the
needle might actually be moved
Steve White's my colleagues from the NFL
Media Group here on the Rich Eisen show
so have you spoken to any player
over the weekend to see how the
commissioners video landed Steve I have
and I would say the majority feel like
let's wait and see but I think for some
of them hearing him say you know the NFL
would not exist without his black
players yeah it may seem obvious but for
it to come from his lips when in so many
previous years
including in the previous weeks they
didn't hear this they're like okay let's
see I still think there is judging the
people I spoke to this hidden fear
hopelessness that their own particular
owners may come in and squat on things
and that's where I think the next the
the next layer of this is going to be
because we haven't heard from too many
owners you know we've had one heard from
Jack York we've seen statements but we
haven't heard anything since Roger
Goodell said what he said and so I think
a lot of these teams like okay Roger
Goodell said this but my owner has told
me to toe the line you know and so if I
go out and do something that goes
against this what one could be the
potential backlash geez let's not forget
Colin Kaepernick does not have a job and
everybody in the NFL has seen that
recognized it and knows it for taking
his stand I think the players feel
emboldened but I do think there's also
that little bit of fear but because we
do not have guaranteed contracts like
like NBA players that there could also
be some type of repercussions so what is
the deal with Kaepernick do you think
that this does I'll ask this a Peter
King later on do you think that this
does lead to a team being able to feel
comfortable with whatever I guess Joe
Lockhart put into a piece for CNN couple
weeks ago talking about his tenure with
the NFL that some teams might us you
know be concerned about a financial and
season ticket base holder backlash when
we're seeing what's happening in the
streets now and we're seeing how how it
wasn't about the anthem never was and
not about the flag never was it was
about bringing attention to what clearly
has a lot of people's attention in a
manner that we've never seen before like
that video from Commissioner Roger
Goodell I mean any possibility that
Kaepernick does get a gig no I mean
there's a possibility to R if you're
Colin Kaepernick and let's just say
something let's just say the New York
Jets call you okay I want to bring you
in wouldn't it feel patronizing you've
had three years to already do this and
now there's this uproar like Google it's
okay now let's make our move for cap who
hasn't had an opportunity to play for
four three seasons so I would think if
I'm him I'm looking at this cynically
you know he's looked a lot I think
cynically we saw that last you know with
the workout in Atlanta where he didn't
trust a lot of the things that the NFL
was trying to do so maybe a team reaches
out is a genuine though is it just
something to sit short gesture I mean I
think those are those are legitimate
questions anyone would have to ask
because all of these teams know the cap
was better than a lot of people that
have come through the NFL on those three
seasons and they did not give him a
chance but now that there's this seeming
C challenge in the country and in the
NFL then now you reach out to him
III you know I just really don't know
and I don't and I don't know if he would
be interested right now because again it
does seem very patronizing if if a team
would step up but maybe if he still
wants to play maybe you'll say what the
hell Pat sizing or not I'm gonna go show
I can do this yeah because at some point
I mean when when when would the right
time be ever if not I guess again you
you tell me because I as you know
talking to you off air and on air and
yeah you know I'm loath to make a
statement
you know
about what someone should do I'm the 50
year old soon to be 51 year old white
Jewish guy you know who's never been
profiled behind the wheel of a car etc
so on and so forth so at some point
though does it you know shouldn't
shouldn't he be back in the NFL I mean
that's he should he's good enough that
point him in 2017 I mean you know we did
a whole lot of woulda shoulda couldas
here but again we're almost we're
entering now four years we are on the
verge we are two months away from four
years I'm not standing for the national
anthem three years I'm taking a snap in
the NFL so if he truly wants to play
like he says he does and a team comes
calling even if you're looking at it
cynically this is an opportunity so what
are you going to do what are you going
to do so it'll be it'll be very
interesting you know after being at that
workout fiasco in Atlanta last year over
the league had 25 teams there and there
were because I was there and then he
decides to work out at an alternate site
which basically left seven or eight
teams there to watch him work out he
says he wants to play he says he wants
to do this he says he's training we
haven't heard from cap other than some
things he's retweeted and posted in
social media but I just I honestly don't
know where his head is and I don't know
what a team would do right now we see
that almost all these teams have got
their quarterback roster set Cam Newton
doesn't have a job right now so are you
gonna sign cap over cam I mean it's
gonna be an interesting situation for a
team to see which direction they had to
I I honestly don't think it's going to
happen but maybe it does and if it does
is it genuine that's that's a big you
know cartoon bubble I have over my head
you know just just filled with cynicism
Steve White's here on the Richardson
show when you saw him sitting from the
press box was a that was in Santa Clara
right you're sitting in the press box or
Clara you're looking down national
anthem
you see number seven taking a seat you
went up to him after the game what'd he
say to you when you asked him well I
mean look you know the hole the hole I
had a whole game to do on this direct
and I've told this before you know I I
was thinking man all summer long I you
know I saw a social media he was really
getting into blacklivesmatter it was
really finding a public voice about
police brutality and so I'm thinking
this is going on so I approached him
just basically like is this what you
sitting was about he's like absolutely
he's like we have black men unarmed
black men getting killed by police and
there's dead bodies laying in the
streets while these police officers are
getting unpaid leave or even paid leave
I think he said paid leave so it's the
same thing the same thing cap said in
2016 is the same thing we're saying
right now that's the same message
nothing has changed except for the years
and it came at a time in an election
cycle same scenario and it's almost like
you sit back like he told us here we are
again
but it seems rich I think because we
didn't we didn't hear this outburst for
a Matar very early or the summer or
Brianna Taylor but I think so many
people because of the kovat we're home
we have no distraction and seeing George
Floyd call out for his mother while this
police officer has his knee on his neck
looking at the sky like he's imagining
sunsets in Jamaica struck a chord that
wow this is real this really does happen
we've heard people say but it really
does happen and that's why I think we're
seeing so many white people and Latino
people and Native people and Asian
people protest and cry hours before
a lot of those voices and advocates were
not there so I again it feels it feels
like something is different we'll see if
anything changes but it feels like there
there really is a movement you know
taking taking hold a few more minutes
left with Steve like my colleague from
NFL Network and NFL media group here on
the Rich Eisen show so what does change
look like if you know a Kaepernick I
guess as you say would be viewed him
being offered a gig could be viewed by
him and so many others as a platitude
just as is just an empty gesture based
on the history so then what is being
about it the step by step being about it
that we talked about Drew Brees actually
using his platform to stop and what he
was hoping for cold the polarization
políticas the polis the politicizing of
of what we absolutely feel is going to
happen coming up this fall you know
should there be national anthems shown
because there won't be any fans
potentially that's I guess for another
day down the road
what what happens what's that what's the
change is when when will be player
players be given the the platform to
protest and all 32 owners will be like
sure including you mentioned the Jets I
mean the the Jets are owned by the
current ambassador to the UK for this
current administration I mean let's be
honest here there there are gonna be
some owners that may not see the
situation in the manner in which drew
Brees now sees it and the Commissioner
now sees it what does change look like
Steve well it's good to me to me I think
it's gonna come in a variety of forms
sure there may be public like change
such as some owners allowing players to
take any fan dissatisfaction be damned
otherwise I'm not gonna like it they
know their markets but
it also could come more subtly you know
besides the lead you know they the lead
to put money into a lot of things right
but if some of these clears the Malcolm
shanks into the world we know about but
if some other players the Pat mahomes in
the world if their start doing if they
start doing things who helped change the
restructuring of their local police
departments you know if they help with
the de-escalation tactics and things
like this I mean it's happening some
places players coalition exchange I'll
help change several laws in different
states to help juvenile delinquents and
the court system you know I think it's
all depends on the player or if it all
depends on the team what they want to do
but if they're sincere change to what
they want to target for a certain NFL
team maybe it's looking at their hiring
practice practices and instead of having
you know a person of color in this
department well maybe you know adding
another one in another department I
think it to me that comes in all
workplaces in a lot of things in society
it's going to be on different levels to
how we view different things which you
look at this Kovach case it's affect the
Kovan pandemic it's affecting black and
brown people disproportionately to white
people so maybe some of these players or
team said okay maybe we start something
healthcare wise or food and nutrition
wise in our communities
- maybe level the scales to do things -
to decrease blood pressure and so many
people and and things like that so I
think it to take different forms on the
football field and off the football
field but clearly there there's so many
levels of the leveling that need to take
place
we'll see who's about it we'll see who's
really into it and we'll see who's all
about the flashy PR statement to make
them feel better about themselves before
I let you go Steve why should I give you
the floor as a Howard University
graduate the passing of ken Riley at the
age
seventy two three-time pro-bowler and
florida am great i saw your tweet about
his passing and i give you the floor on
to who he was and what you want to say
about him steve cool thank you that rich
i mean i i've known for a while he's a
number the black college football hall
of fame and for those who don't know
that the hall of fame there recognizes
players who went to black colleges I've
known Ken quiet man
very astute scholarly man he was a
finalist in college for a Rhodes
Scholarship was a great player for the
Cincinnati Bengals a lot of will say he
should be in the Pro Football Hall of
Fame at the time of his retirement he
was fourth all-time in interceptions
behind three Hall of Famers but more
importantly he was a coach and athletic
director at Florida A&M and in suit the
lives of so many young men who have gone
on to become very productive members of
the society great leaders that is you
know it does as important as anything he
ever did on the football field so rest
in peace ken Riley those of us who know
you are hurt those who didn't are
affected and hopefully one day Peter
King wrote in his column today is he
gets into the Pro Football Hall of Fame
as a member of the senior committee
because he's very deserving and a lot of
the people he played with and against
will tell you as much Steve you're
you're you're one of the best I love
being able to call you a friend and I
look forward to a playing season there's
gonna be one right I mean we're we're
gonna we are gonna this is gonna go this
season's gonna go it really looks like a
rich it looks like it's gonna go looks
like gonna go off on schedule I think
the only question now is will he be fans
and if so how many and again you're the
best and I really appreciate you have me
on rich and I and I do treasure having
you as a friend as well I appreciate you
saying that because you know it does
feel like things are changing it does
feel like things are different it does
feel like things are changing for the
better and I I know
again you have been literally having a
front-row seat on this part of the NFL
story from the very beginning and I
wanted to have you on certainly I did
not know you and MJ had moderated that
panel on Friday I was sitting here on
the show and I heard nothing but amazing
things about it and I appreciate you
coming on and sharing everything well
thanks again rich you the back that's
Steve watch follow them on Twitter at
y89
I follow them on Twitter you should as
well